Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How's it going?
It's going great.
You sound excited.
What's going on?
I am preparing a surprise party.
How fun!
What is the party for?
A friend of mine is pregnant.
That's lovely.
So, what is your plan?
First of all, we're inviting all of her friends.
What else?
We'll be decorating a party room and then wrapping all the gifts.
What are you getting for her?
I got her packs of diapers.
Are you getting any munchies?
I think we are going to bring our own dishes.
That's a good idea.
It will save you some time.
And of course, we will hide ourselves.
That's the fun part.
Yes, but remember not to shout, "Surprise!"
You know, she's pregnant.
Right.
I almost forgot.
Have fun!